hi everyone Matt here thanks for tuning
in before we get started with this great
episode I'd like to invite you to join
us on LinkedIn
find the think fast talk smart page and
follow us for conversation updated
information new ideas and a great
opportunity for us to interact
the word communication comes from the
Latin to make common or to share in
other words communication is about
relaying our ideas feelings and thoughts
to others
the goal of our speech is most often
what I jokingly refer to as our
communication f word no not that f word
but rather Fidelity which means the
accuracy and Clarity of the messages we
share today we are going to visit with
four designers who can help us make our
communication hit the mark and make sure
that it's designed with our audience in
mind
hello I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach
strategic communication at Stanford
Graduate School of Business welcome to
think fast talk smart the podcast
in my many years at Stanford I've
learned that if I want to find
innovative ideas for solving complex
problems a great place to go is Stanford
d-school the d stands for design and the
d-school is world famous for many things
including teaching design thinking
recently the d-school released a series
of four guidebooks one on Courage one on
belonging one on ambiguity and one on
visualization these topics apply to many
domains of our personal and professional
lives and they also directly relate to
communication
in this episode I'll introduce you to
the authors of each book and ask them to
help us apply their expertise in design
to our communication to learn more about
each book check the links in our show
notes my first guest is Ashish goel he
is a designer and a former teaching
fellow at the Stanford D School his book
is drawing on Courage as many of you
listeners know I've written a book
studied and helped people develop
courage and confidence in their
communication so it's nice to find
someone else who's very interested in
the topic as well Ashish breaks down
courage into four components I started
by asking him what they are and how this
typology helps us to be more courageous
let me first ask you Matt what was
something you did recently that took a
little bit of Courage
so as many of the listeners know I have
teenagers in my house and I I had to
step up a little bit and give some
pretty constructive feedback and that's
a bit of Courage
so you know courage can be something
uh like a journey that can last just a
few hours which it might have taken in
your case or it can last months let's
say choosing to start a business you
have been mulling over and I think all
gutted Journeys have four stops fear
values action and change
the first stop is fear because you don't
know how things will turn out which is
why it takes courage the second stop is
your values there is a reason why you're
choosing to do this in the first place
that's because you value what lies on
the other side the third stop is action
the real moment of Courage and the
fourth stop is change what happened
after you acted with courage I think
this typology can help people be more
courageous first because it helps you
diagnose which where are you stuck
are you scared about the risks ahead
then you can reduce them
if you are not clear about why this
matters to you have you clarified and
committed to your values
have you done both of those things but
it's just that moment of action when
you're chickening out
or
you have acted with courage and now
you're just grappling with the
consequences
so these four components to me help you
diagnose and then rectify
with stop of the kind of Journey you may
be struggling with I really appreciate
delineating the different aspects that
go into courage and then how they can
help us create an action plan to to
accomplish the task that we have I
really appreciate that and and wish that
I would have deployed that kind of
thinking when I had to talk to my son so
uh next time and I fear there will be a
next time so thank you and then there
are moments when you don't have the time
to reflect some you can always reflect
back on something on a moment when you
did or did not act with got it so that's
that's a way to use this typology as
well certainly and and I I will
definitely leverage it to think about
how things went and how they could have
been different for the next time when it
comes to actually thinking about and
thinking through the messages those
challenging messages that you you need
to give yes any advice on how best to
Muster that courage to to actually do
the delivery one idea that I love is
actually from a class at the GSB
interpersonal Dynamics or what they call
touchy feely where they talk about the
net so there's a net and you're on one
side you know your feelings what
happened and why you felt the way you
felt but we often assume uh intentions
on the other side of the net
so one thing that can help you
courage is to use that conversation as a
learning conversation where you get to
share your side of the net and you get
to learn more about what their side
of the story was
um and that can make it less about
delivering critical feedback or engaging
in the conflict and more about figuring
it out together I really love that
collaborative approach and seeing the
the value that it has for you but also
for the other person to deliver that
message and we we have had previously on
the podcast both Carol and David who are
instrumental in architecting the
interpersonal Dynamics class and and
they did talk about the net a little bit
and you added good value to their
conversation so thank you absolutely
Having the courage to share our ideas
feelings and thoughts is the starting
point for all effective communication we
can't clearly communicate if we aren't
confident in our message and confident
in our ability to communicate it next we
need to consider how we bring the
audience along with us we can't just
talk at our audience we must make our
content meaningful and relevant focusing
on the concept of belonging can help us
in this endeavor my next guest is Dr
Susie wise Susie is a designer and
teacher who directs the K-12 lab Network
for the Stanford d-school and is
co-creator of liberatory design her book
is designed for belonging Susie I'm
curious how do you define belonging and
why is it so important thank you
so I Define belonging
as an essential human need first and
foremost we need to know that we belong
in order to show up and share our skills
our talents our abilities our identities
our personalities all of Who We Are
so belonging is the feeling that lets us
know that that's possible it might look
like being invited and welcomed it might
look like being able to provide critical
feedback it might look like being able
to contribute how can we help others to
feel a sense of belonging what can we do
as friends as colleagues as managers or
leaders to invite that feeling of
belonging the frame that I'm using right
now is designed for belonging the idea
is that belonging is of course it's a
feeling so anyone's going to have it
themselves in whatever way they do
so as Leaders as managers we're looking
to create the context to design the
context where belonging can emerge and
that can look in any number of different
ways so what I try to do is offer a
framework around feeling seeing and
shaping belonging and the seeing
belonging really matters that's looking
at what kinds of moments are you
creating where people are feeling like
they're able to show up and be
themselves it also means feeling and
seeing into moments where belonging
isn't really what people are feeling and
seizing those as opportunities to create
change then you open up the toolkit of
design
you're able to shape it and that looks
like not just sending an email but
thinking about how space or role or
ritual how new kinds of communication
how many different I like to call them
lovers of design but that's really just
a fancy way of saying things that you
can create help people to come together
and comfortably share who they are I
love the seeing the feeling and the
shape excellent I'm curious do you have
some specific advice for both our
personal and professional communication
for how we can foster that sense of
belonging are the things we can say or
shouldn't say anything in our
communication that you can help us with
so communication is a huge lever for
belonging I like to think about
Communications and how it relates to
belonging a lot in the book I actually
call out communication as one of the
levers to design with and that's in part
because representation and authentic
storytelling are some of the ways that
we get cues for when and where we can
belong and that is really important it's
also very true that one of the things
that a leader can do to invite more
belonging is by creating more mechanisms
for storytelling more places where you
can show up and share more parts of
yourself
that you can come together and actually
share stories that of things that people
don't know about or might not be
precisely germane to your position but
it actually matter to you sharing what
matters to you and sharing how you can
contribute is a huge part of belonging
and storytelling and Communications are
natural human ways that we can share
some of that I love that advice for
leaders to provide opportunities for
people to share their stories and to
bring who they are to their
communication that's fantastic
being driven by an empathetic
audience-centric approach that Fosters
belonging especially when paired with
confidence can allow us to better craft
meaningful High Fidelity messages yet in
order to make our messages clear we need
to address ambiguity and become
comfortable with it
excited to be here today with Andrea
small Andrea is a design leader
strategist and educator she teaches at
Stanford's d-school and leads
storytelling and design strategy for
Samsung research America's r d
Innovation team Andrea has worked with
some of the most iconic brands in the
world thanks for being here Andrew
thanks for having me it's awesome and
your book is super exciting it's titled
navigating ambiguity creating
opportunity in a world of unknowns and I
have to share with you ambiguity is
something that really spurred my whole
interest in communication I've always
been fascinated by how we use ambiguity
to actually manage some really important
communication needs like being polite
like trying to convince people of what
we're trying to convince them for and
little known to many people I actually
think it's fascinating how it plays out
in flirtation and that's some research I
did way back in the day so let's begin
ambiguity is the topic of our time and
people have strong discomfort with it
how can we design our communication in a
way that creates calm and even
encourages creativity and progress yes
that's a big question and the way that I
think about designing our communication
to create calm is to keep it organized
which might be the opposite of ambiguity
not all of our communication should be
ambiguous
particularly if you're say the CDC and
you're communicating mask mandates or
something you need to be exceptionally
clear we can design communication that
encourages creativity that encourages
people to bring themselves into that and
by creating space we allow people to
kind of see themselves in what we're
saying and we're not closing all of the
loops for them we're not necessarily
telling them how we think they should
react to that we're allowing for that to
happen so in many ways it sounds like
providing structure and guidelines can
help people managed through this
creativity and feel more comfortable
we're often told that we need to be very
clear in our communication yet some of
our most important and risky
communication is purposely ambiguous I'm
curious you to get your thoughts on this
tension of ambiguity versus Clarity
ambiguity is navigating those tensions
that tensions allow for creativity to
exist and design really thrives off of
tensions so that tension between Clarity
and uncertainty or the known and the
unknown the in-between is where creative
ideas can really flourish and come to
life
I feel like the need for clarity and
communication is really context
dependent you know it depends on what
you're saying and who you're saying it
to and when
um you know we use ambiguity in the book
a little bit to invite the reader into
what we're trying to say and we don't
necessarily fill in all of the blanks we
leave places for there to be ambiguity
but if you're too ambiguous it's
confusing you could lose people we don't
want to be so esoteric in our
communication that people have nothing
to grip onto so grounding it in some
places being clear being direct is
really important so that you can have
that freedom to explore or leave things
open-ended so the you know the structure
and the openness is really a balance
excellent so I I had this image in my
mind of a bowling lane and a bumper
guard in so the ball never misses and I
think that that that's really helpful
because as as managers As Leaders we
want to create spaces and time for
people to play with the tensions and
ambiguity
and then develop communication that
supports that but at the same time we
need to meet deadlines and we need to
make sure that we're achieving our goals
so uh really interesting and and I I
think a lot in the corporate world is
Let's Be super clear let's meet the
deadline and what I hear you say is we
have to set up space for those tensions
to live in the ambiguity that comes with
it yeah it's it's difficult because in
innovation in uh you know for example
working in advanced technology we don't
have all of the answers and all big
risks involve stepping into that
ambiguity so a lot of my job as a
strategist is then risk mitigation for
the leadership to help them feel
comfortable in the leaps that we're
taking because we're looking at things
much further out into the future and
they're not things that can necessarily
be measured today so a lot of it is uh
kind of that anxiety uh the anxiety
management absolutely absolutely you
said something that really resonated
with me that Innovation is really
stepping into ambiguity and that I think
is very profound I think I need to think
about that some more but I I love it and
I love that people do what you do to
help people feel comfortable with that I
find the tensions between Clarity and
ambiguity both fascinating and helpful
they force us to clearly think about our
communication intent as well is impact
with this Focus we can then begin to map
out and visualize our stories in the
information they contain
my final guest is Carissa Carter she is
a designer geoscientist and the academic
director at the Stanford d-school
Carissa drives the d-schools pedagogy
and teaches courses on the intersection
of data and Design
her book is called The Secret Language
of maps is there research or in your own
experience are there things that help
data be more easily processed by people
so people actually take the message more
quickly
use of color use of space are there
other is there advice or guidance you
can give us in terms of best practices
yeah I mean I would say know your know
your audience in the way that they want
to take in information so we actually
map our audience before creating
something for them so what's the context
context is a component of craft what's
the context that's going to be viewed
are you going to make something that
should be laid on the big table in a
library and we all have to be really
quiet while we look at it
are you putting something in a in a
board presentation and people are going
to be sitting around a table looking at
a screen
in or are you going to plaster something
on the side of a building in the middle
of a city and people are going to be
walking past it
if you know the context it's going to
you can then think to well what do I
need to include in it in order to make
it really land with that audience
I think that's a really important Point
we've talked a lot on this podcast about
knowing your audience in terms of your
messaging I think a lot of us just
default to standard slide creation tools
or just bullet points when it comes to
taking the data and the information that
we're trying to present visually and not
really applying those same principles of
how's the audience going to receive it
what's the context in which they're
going to receive it and that can really
help so thank you for sharing that I
think that's a that's a taking a lesson
we know in one domain and applying it to
another that can be really helpful yeah
I mean you're actually describing that
that creative tension between data and
craft right there right you may want to
be making something that that that lands
in a really soft Gentle Way with your
audience but if all you know is the
default blue that outputs on PowerPoint
right that's just not going to work so
evolving evolving your tools to meet the
needs of the message you want is
something we aim for that's a really
important Point evolving the tools to
meet the way you want your information
to land very very very important without
misleading or being deceitful how can we
design communication to help us achieve
our goals for example convince people to
agree with us to hire us to support our
ideas or projects
well we can be really in tune with what
our agenda is
is our agenda
to invite others in and to explore a
topic to see all of the information
is our agenda to tell you a point
is our agenda to create an aha moment
or do we really want to convince to
manipulate
and if so that's where we're tugging on
the levers of what information to
include what data to include what craft
to use which way to present
if you are genuinely making a map or an
infographic that you want people to you
know change their behavior about it
comes back right to knowing the cultural
context of the audience that you're
working with
the needs that they have at any given
moment what they're hoping for from the
communication to
the point about having a clear agenda
and using that to drive the choices you
make is really important I often find in
my own life when I've got to use some
data and I know it's going to help me
leverage a goal or achieve a goal I have
I just rush to get it done because it's
usually the last thing I do and the
point I'm hearing you say is I have to
step back really reflect on the agenda
and then use that agenda to help decide
what tools and approach I use you you do
right and you your agenda right that's
the story
is it possible to use some of these data
mapping ideas that you're talking about
to help us actually craft the narratives
and stories that we tell
a thousand percent okay I call it a
glorion before you explain in the same
way that if you were going to go out to
a concert you probably would try on
three or four different outfits to see
what looks good before right you know
you choose what you're gonna wear
we want to explore with our data with
our agenda our story with our craft
before we land on the final output one
of my favorite ways to do some of that
exploring before we explain is to use a
Continuum now a Continuum is as simple
as a line with two arrows
I think of it as the most elegant map
that exists
and you can think of a Continuum as
a timeline a transition
tension from then to now
from
um
solid to liquid
from strength to weakness
right you can you can find those in any
story and if you find the timelines that
transitions the tensions in the story
that you want to tell then you can find
the data that is going to support those
stories then you can figure out what is
the craft how do you want to wrap that
story in a visual language in order to
meet the needs of your audience
I love the idea of exploring before
explaining and I'm really excited to
apply this because it really turns on
its head have your story first then
figure out how to use the data you're
actually saying use the the the data
techniques the mapping techniques to
help you find your story
and I think that's really fun and
exciting absolutely you can
if lore before you explain you can start
your Exploration with story you can
start your Exploration with data or you
can start your Exploration with craft
right if you know that you want your
story your data story to appear at the
at the big Retreat you're going to have
with the whole organization maybe you
want to present a visual that's on the
water bottle everybody's gonna give out
so I use that context that water bottle
context as a constraint so what could be
revealed slowly as somebody spins it in
their hand
so you start there you could explore
with craft first and then figure out the
story and then figure out the data
thank you that's amazingly Illuminating
and really really helpful
how can we spot visual data or
communication that's trying to persuade
or perhaps even mislead us
well I'll start out by saying I don't
think most people are trying to mislead
us
but it happens unintentionally all the
time
my trick for you
is to watch out for limp data tell me
more
limb data is exactly what it sounds like
for whatever reason the data doesn't
stand up when you're looking at a
visualization is it clear where the data
came from what were the boundaries of it
the boundaries of data are never
clear-cut and let me give you an example
of that if I said Matt how many dollars
are in your pocket what what would you
say literally right now uh 23
right
so 23 might be the cash you have in your
pocket but do you have a credit card too
I have a couple yeah okay so does
dollars when I say dollars does that
extend to your credit card
a balance you might have on that card or
your credit limit sure but that's not
what I first thought right but but what
what is included what isn't yeah you
know the boundaries of what data is or
what any any terminology anything that
we're measuring are the person that made
that made some decisions
they decided dollars might be just cash
they decided that dollars May extend all
the way into
mortgage you might have on your home
limp data is a great example of using
language to represent a concept in a
visual way just like you're talking
about and it leads me to think that
there is this Synergy that happens
between the visual Realm and the wording
that you use that when congruent can
actually be much more powerful than
either separate that is such a great
point the words on our visualizations
they matter so much too
let's say I have a a bar graph that is
showing me the number of leaves of
different types in a forest
if you title that number of leaves of
different types in the forest I don't
know is that interesting it's as
interesting as it could be right right
if I title it with a very scientific
sounding title it's clear it's for a
scientific audience if I instead title
it things that made lots of noise as I
walked today
it welcomes in the Casual Observer right
so the words matter absolutely
absolutely and I I love that visual uh
that is created in our mind by the
language that you use a big thank you
Ashish Susie Andrea and Carissa each of
your insights all related to design and
communication are so useful and clear I
hope we can all apply them to our
communication and as with every show I
asked all four guests the same three
questions we end each episode with we're
going to play one answer from each of my
guests
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title what would it be
don't fold your arms
all right tell me more tell me more I
actually learned this from Diane Klein
who you I'm sure you know who teaches
improv at Stanford University and I we
had him do a workshop in a d-school
class and each time he would
uh like tap someone on the wrist if they
had if they had their arms folded and
following your arms is a way about being
defensive so when you open your arms
your body shapes is like a stance with
which you operate it's about dropping
your defenses staying open so it allows
for
more authentic and honest back and forth
to happen
rather than when everyone is just
folding their arms and
keeping themselves safe
first we we've had Dan Klein on the
podcast before and he's fantastic and I
love this note I love this notion of how
you show up what you do physically
matters and there is a distancing that
happens when you you fold your arms and
not only does it have an impact on the
people you're communicating with it has
an impact on yourself as you alluded to
it changes the way you approach the
communication so I love that and we have
never had anybody give an answer that
was non-verbal in that way so thank you
here's Susie with one Communicator she
admires and why so you shared those
ahead of time and I really liked it and
so I was thinking about it in the book I
have a set of what I call host Heroes
okay so I was thinking about some of
those folks
um and some are famous like brene brown
but the person I thought I wanted to
share today is a professor at Stanford
her name is Elita Hayes she teaches
dance
and that might seem an unlikely way to
think about Communications or being a
communicator but what she invites people
to do and at the d-school we partner
with her a lot for executive education
programs for different experiences for
students
and what she does is invite
everyone and to dance but she does it in
such a simple and slow way that you find
yourself surprised that you're actively
in a dance you wouldn't have signed up
to dance in the atrium of the d-school
and yet there you are and it feels
incredibly moving and motivating so I
think of that as an essential kind of
communication and a great reminder to
embody our thoughts and our feelings and
recognize that as communication as well
absolutely the embodiment of
communication is really important and we
have spent some time on this podcast
talking about how we use our body but I
that's a great reminder and it seems
very scary to me that I might be dancing
in front of others but I can see it as a
very free and and fun activity that
Brilliance is she brings you slowly into
it
um and really her community
is is what lets you take those steps so
she breaks down tiny pieces that get
added up you start by just imagining
you're walking down the street in New
York City for instance right interesting
so she moves you so you get moving and
here's Andrea and Carissa's answers to
perhaps my favorite question what are
the three ingredients in a successful
communication recipe
passion
differentiation and humor ah I love
passion and humor make a lot of sense
talk a little bit more about
differentiation I think in at least in
the corporate world
we have started to align people to a
certain specific way of speaking or
doing or acting or leading and I think
differentiating yourself from everybody
else finding your own voice
being honest and true to yourself versus
trying to fit into a mold that somebody
else created is very important and you
know back to the risk management and
ambiguity when we have more
differentiation we have more diversity
we're opening ourselves to even more
unknowns and I would want to encourage
people to to find what makes them stand
out in their in a sea of other people
communicating what is the thing that
will make you different and that might
be you know again context dependent on
what what it is you're presenting or
what it is you're speaking about so
differentiation I love the idea that we
all need to find our unique
offering in our communication and really
focus on that separate some of the noise
from the signal there
thank you I appreciate you unequivocally
helping us disambiguate ambiguity thank
you so much and finally here's Carissa
with her three ingredients that go into
a successful communication recipe I'm
going to present you my recipe in the
form of a Venn diagram
very appropriate
in one Circle I have map your audience
no the knee
in another Circle
I have
know your own intentions like what
drives you what inspires you
and then in the third one
it's well what's the content what's the
material
and it's that that place in the middle
of all three of those
that's what you should talk about
there's always more you could say or
ways you could be but just hone in on
what comes in the middle of those three
circles so that's the aim the audience
the intention and the material and it's
that overlap that makes for the best
recipe it's all about the overlaps the
topics tools and tips are for guests
shared provide some of the key building
blocks to how we approach and execute on
creating High Fidelity messages
I know if we all apply these ideas of
confidence belonging ambiguity and
mapping to our communication we will be
more successful in sharing our messages
and increasing their Fidelity I invite
you to check out the show notes to learn
more about the d-school guide books
you've been listening to think fast talk
smart the podcast a production of
Stanford Graduate School of Business
this episode was produced by Podium
podcast company Jenny Luna and me Matt
Abrahams find more resources follow and
join our conversation on LinkedIn by
searching think fast talk smart please
download and follow wherever you get
your podcasts and be sure to drop us a
review on Spotify or apple podcasts
foreign